- Okay, so be honest.
I, and, and when I say, be honest,
I mean, lying is totally okay.
How did I do with your song?
(laughing)
Did you hear it?
- Awesome.
I noticed that you had to change the key,
It was in a girl key.
- I know I'm a first soprano, man.
I always have to raise
everything 'cause I can't go low,
I can go high.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
God bless you for it,
but yeah, it was cool.
Thank you for doing that.
- Oh my gosh, no, I'm such,
we're all such big fans.
So where were you in life
when you wrote It's My Life
and what does it mean to you?
- For me, it was Frankie,
like there's a lyric and it says,
like Frankie said, I did it my way.
That was from New
Jersey's most famous son,
Frank Sinatra
and I had just come home from doing a film
in Malta and Rome
called U-571,
it was a World War II picture
with Matthew McConaughey
and we'd come home and we're
making the Crush record
and, and we got together to write that
and I had to fight very
hard for that lyric.
And, and Richie said to me,
"What is Frankie and what does it matter?:
And I says, "Well,
because much like Frank,
I'm gonna make movies when
I want, records when I want
and this is how I'm feeling."
And I won the argument simply
because I had to sing
the song every night,
but, and that's what it stood for for me.
But the magic was is guys like Anthony
and people around the world,
they said, no, Frankie is me,
Frankie's my best friend,
Frankie's my brother
and that's the magic of a great song
is people make it their own.
- Yeah. I love the message,
yeah that you can get.
That's the most interesting thing
I think performing shows
and meeting fans
afterwards and everything,
everybody has their own
kind of take on a song
that you had a completely
different idea about
and why you wrote it.
And I think that's what's
so magical about music.